Richard Branson flying right now
somewhere I don't know Richard Branson
joining us right now so Richard good to
see you you appear to be in first class
naturally looks like seat to a to me
familiar with that seat I'm I'm glad you
I'm glad you know our plane so where are
you sister in Denver and wherever the
mountains at the moment it looks very
beautiful out there and isn't a
knowledge incredible where we are
talking from 35,000 feet well I must say
that at least half me hope that this is
a demonstration of the technology would
fail because I thought it would be good
TV but I think this is a classic virgin
moment of screw it just do it doing a
Skype interview to demonstrate well how
important this Wi-Fi is to your service
talk to me about this switch from gogo
Internet to the faster service of via
set we can now define Wi-Fi incredibly
quickly to all our passengers we were
the first airline to introduce Wi-Fi we
know how popular it is people want to do
their business when they're on a flight
or they want to you know chat to their
friends and so it's been really
important so this switch I think it's
going to be a good one Wendy as you
chose this route to Denver why SFO
Denver it's been interesting to look at
your marketing materials on this that
have been really focusing on the
technology community naturally in San
Francisco and Silicon Valley but also
Denver Virgin America's success I think
it's largely clean technology driven so
attracting young young tech people has
been very very important for virgin and
because we're based in San Francisco we
I think we get we get the land share of
them but then there's also a wonderful
city to go for skiing for mountain
hiking for you know if you want to join
and you go to Denver but it's
plots what's a recreational everything
going on in Denver and it's a fun place
for getting to thirth what is it about
the the things that you do and the big
businesses you take on you know things
that might not typically attract the
interest of entrepreneurs and startup
people and yet virgin has done that what
do you think it is about the the way
that you pursued your business that
speaks to the entrepreneurs and startup
people you can't you're just going
through some turbulence oh excuse me if
we've bounced and no look I think I I
see situations where I feel it you know
things are not being run well so the the
American airline system ten years ago it
didn't have a decent airline so so I
thought you know let's let's launch
Virgin America let's create the best
airline in America and if you create the
best of anything you'll do well and
you'll survive and I think Virgin
America it's now nine at nine years out
of the last nine years we've been voted
best airline in the States as a team
we've done a great job and therefore we
attract those leisure people and tech
people who you know what you know one
wanted want to be flowing in a slightly
more hip airline than our competitors so
the big question for you finally once
you get to Denver snowboarding or skiing
I do babe I know III scale it my
daughter and I snowboarding my son and I
get to do both
sadly I'm going to be in Turkey tomorrow
morning so I'm there for about two hours
and I ask for trouble anyway off the top
doctor turkey straight up but I get
there but next time I'll come back now I
can I've got an airline that flies there
I can afford to go there next time with
a bee sting fabulous Sir Richard Branson
from 35,000 I wanna get you in trouble
the flight attendant so I'll let you
shut down this Skype thank you for
joining us and enlighten great alright
another kind of surfing there's some mai
tai opportunities this summer I intend
to take advantage of